greetings and welcome back to yet
another analysis from the uh
skilling open today on the table we got
the jan chrysostom duda against taimur
rajabov
and boy the latter rajab
he is on a roll he's on a three-game
winning streak
three wins in a row here three out of
three today so far
an absolute uh dream day
and the boy the games have been
incredible
there are no other words to describe it
his games have been absolutely
a joy to watch and uh i can't wait to
show you guys
this game against the polish duda here
so
let's uh begin with knight f3 knight of
six
g3 very common uh start here a very
calm start here from um from jan
chrysostom duda
with g3 fairly solid it's not interested
in a
dynamic fight p3
and bishop g7 it should be two
everything is fairly standard uh so far
not the most common opening but believe
it or not this is played quite a bit
it's just it's a strategic rich opening
which is sometimes very
obnoxious for black to play i play this
quite a lot with black and it's not so
simple here the most common approach is
d5
bishop g2 castles castles c6
and c4 this position is played a lot
and it's not actually
more dangerous than it seems and fairly
critical
but rajabov he goes for different
approach
c5 the chances of this game transposing
into a weird english
is very possible now that the pawn is on
c5 bishop g2 d6
different approach again from rajabov
you can obviously play d5
and here the game will be completely
completely different
it's just a matter of taste really d6
castles e5 and the point here is that
black gets a great grip on the d4 d4
square
but the only downside is that it could
be weakening the d5 square
quite a bit but with the bishop on b2
it's not so easy to exploit that
normally in the english opening
especially in these positions
you put your bishop on g5 and then you
take on f6 and then play knight d2
followed by knight t5 knight e4
but this is a very different move order
so
so e5 is better here i'd say
c4 castles knight c3
knight c6 everything is fairly fairly
logical so far
i do have to admit that i do like i
think black has
gotten a nice position i don't think he
has any problems
d3 from duda and h6 the point of this
move is that black wants to prevent
knight g5
so now if rajabov had played bishop e6
he always needs to watch out for knight
g5 which is slightly annoying
because now we can jump to e4 with with
a tempo
so rajaba wants to avoid that he plays
h6
and then duda jumps to d2 same plan he
wants to play an id4 at some point or
even knight t5
bishop e6 rook c1
and queen d7 from rajabo
maybe he can potentially play bishop h3
and exchange these two bishops
the bishop on g2 is known as
light strength in these positions so
it's uh it's an advantage to to trade
them up trade them off
but it's easier said than done
a3 it's still possible to play bishop h3
uh i can't see anything wrong with it so
i'm sure it
was a possibility but rajabo went for
rook c8 which is another logical move
duda would like to play b4 here which
could maybe be possible in this position
at least it seems to me like an
interesting sacrifice to
maybe play queen b3 or even bishop a3
here and the knight b5 to attack on d6
looks fairly interesting i'm not sure if
it works but
the computer doesn't hate it so then it
can't be too bad
it's always an interesting option and
that's white's plan here so
in order to advance his position white
needs to play b4 b5 at some point
so b4 is a natural try at least
but knight t5 is another very logical
move
b6 from rajabov here i would say that b4
again
is very possible and then play b5 next
or queen a4
maybe even take on c5 in some lines
but yeah i would say b4 is logical but a
dude that goes for bishop c3
i'm not sure if i like that move that
much
but i think he also plans to put his
bishop on d2 in the near future because
the bishop is not really doing that well
on b2
due to the fact that this pawn is
blocking the diagonal
bishop g4 came kind of a
prophylactic move he wants to prevent
fight from playing e3 and then in the
future put his knight on d4
knight takes f6 bishop to xf6 knight e4
and bishop g7
and here you can see a disadvantage with
the bishop on c3 because
black cannot play f5 and then knight has
to go back to d2 and he would rather put
his knight on c3
but this is what we see happen though
bishop d2
f5 knight c3 but i think this
is um quite comfortable for black and
the attack is
certainly a little bit unpleasant uh
for white i i would prefer black here
although
the position is roughly equal i'm gonna
i'm gonna guess
but but the attack goes on f4
bishop d5 check king h8 and then do the
place f3
it's a move you do not want to make but
it's
an important move it's a defending move
and
now it's not so simple for
for black to to get through so bishop h3
rook f2 knight e7 bishop b4
you do not want to let black take that
bishop
knight f5 g takes f4 he takes f4 bishop
takes out f4
bishop d4 the position is now becoming
wild
it's very complicated i would be very
scared here if i was i was white but the
position is
once again roughly equal
and if the position is roughly equal i
would prefer white for sure
but 95 let's see what happens rajabo
goes for queen g7 which is actually not
a very good move
and we even we're going to see why in a
second i can quickly mention that g5
probably would have been a better try
just to play this um as soon as possible
and after for example bishop d2 you can
start
playing g4 and now the position you're
opening
up around white's king and this is
extremely extremely dangerous
do you keep in mind that uh taking the
exchange wouldn't be
dangerous at all most of the attack is
gone and we have a
white has a pawn and these two bishops
are very very strong
so white would be much better in a
scenario like that
the queen g7 was played bishop d2 this
is a very good move
and the point is that after g5 we can
now
play e3 this is a very good move
g4 the attack keeps
keeps going the position is extremely
complex
but duda has has a move here which is uh
which is very strong
and that is the logical move king h1
move out of the diagonal
although when you play king h1 you need
to calculate what happens after g3 and
this is not so simple
because the only move here is to calmly
play rook e2
and if that's the only move it's not
easy to make that move over
over the board i can mention however
that if you take
you're lost at the knight x king h2 and
then something like rook g8
the threat is knight f1 followed by by
mates and it's very hard to predict
to prevent also queen g5 queen h4 is in
the air
so rook e2 would have been the only move
and then something like
g takes h2 e takes d4
knight g3 check king h2
knight takes e4 you should probably
save um with a queen
g1 try to trade the queens and
here it would probably be
lead to a draw after rook takes f3
so certainly some play left but this is
fairly
fairly equal a forced sequence
right there which is extremely difficult
to evaluate
as white especially if you're low on
time and
playing a short game as we're doing here
but uh judah he went the he went for
f takes g4 bishop takes g4
queen e1 and queen e1 as the losing move
in
in this position uh the only or there
are a few moves
here that could save the game uh the
best one would be rook g2
and we have a fourth sequence so bishop
takes d1 rook takes g7
bishop takes g7 and rook takes d1 this
position here is
also roughly roughly equal
so that was duda's best try
he could maybe play the queen f1 too but
when you're under attack you want to
trade off the queens
uh as soon as possible so that's why
rook g2 is
probably a better move but queen e1 was
played and here comes the great
combination of bishop f3 check
king f1 and then knight h4 this is the
killer move
and uh it's just all too dangerous for
for the white king
and there is nothing you can do do the
try e takes d4
rajava played bishop g2 and after
one important point as uh it's actually
very nice
if the bishop takes g2 we can simply
capture back with
queen takes g2 now we're we're going to
have queen g4
very important move do not let the king
escape to d1
and after king f1 and rook e8
this position is lost
maybe this should be e3 but something
like c takes d4 here looks killing
taking the piece next
so king e2 was tried but after queen g
queen g4
king e3 and bishop takes e4 bishop c3
and then queen knight g2 uh queen h3
would have been
checkmate just to point that out
but a knight g2 is uh good enough
nonetheless
uh king d2 knight xc1 g65 check
king g8 and um judah resigned so a very
nice attacking game from uh from duke
from rajabov nicely defended by judah as
well we have to hand it to him
it was a very difficult position to
defend and he did find a lot of good
moves but
very often when you're under attack you
need to find the absolute best moves
and you need to play play the best moves
all along the way not just a few moves
and this is
in practice very difficult when you're
low in time and
you're under attack there's so much to
calculate
so hats off to rajabov for for a nice
dynamic
victory and the man is on a roll
that's for sure incredibly impressive uh
by rajabov
who now has three out of three points
so far today stay tuned for for more